Clark County Schools want to nearly
double their police force for the next
school year in order to address school
safety the district estimates that could
cost though millions of dollars to get
it done 8 news now education reporter
Joshua peguera looks at this request as
it comes at a time that our state is
proposing injecting an additional 2.3
billion dollars into our schools
Matthew Caldwell head of the Clark
County Schools Police union says ccsdpd
needs to expand in April he sent a
letter to lawmakers urging the district
get funds to add officers to elementary
and middle schools so I know people hear
that and they say hey we don't want to
criminalize adolescent behavior and I
would tell you that I agree that we
don't want to do that CCSD
superintendent Dr Jesus Jara went to the
legislature in March stating he wants 21
million dollars to create 138 additional
police jobs our teachers can teach our
children don't feel safe CCSD PD
currently has a staff of 190 Personnel
40 are Patrol officers and there are two
officers stationed at high schools in
the valley six of those officers have
canines with four being able to detect
guns if you look at the problems that we
have with guns on campus the the gun
dogs are absolutely necessary and
they're also a good deterrent at a press
conference held on Wednesday at the
building behind me CCSD police chief
Mike black guy says his officers have
seized 30 guns so far this school year
five are from adults and he's urging
parents and relatives to secure their
firearms make sure if you do have a
firearm you know where it's at that your
child is not or does not have access to
it
check their backpacks before they leave
home earlier this week a campus monitor
was shot by a straight Bullet at Von
tobo Middle School Caldwell says an
extra police force would allow officers
to patrol areas near schools Joshua
peguero eight news now
CCSD says next school year it does plan
to roll out metal detectors at some
schools as part of a pilot program